Pascal's Flegel has a whole bunch of
properties very very interesting
properties far beloved I'm gonna talk
about briefly today I bow way it's worth
lady Pascal was not the guy who invented
this triangle he's laid even the first
guy to have spotted the pattern like it
was you can find it in all kinds of
mathematical literature going back
centuries but Pascal did a lot of work
with that and it's not just because he
has a um a cool first name that it got
named after him it's largely owing to
him like come on who names their kid
plays and collected those crazy French
people so blase plus Carl and his
triangle let's notice some things about
it okay let's notice a big for instance
for instance what makes Pascal's
triangle Pascal's triangle how is it
constructed this is the first property
like actually had it spout wet where
does numbers come from it come from
addition right in fact the first and
most important properties called the
addition property right now I'm then I'm
not gonna write it out and lick from the
books or take me awhile but I think you
can see what it's getting at right with
the exception of the first one right and
I'll actually if you put a different
number up there as your starting point
your seed if you like ya know for the
whole different thing but anyway um each
number is composed of the two numbers
immediately above it right on its left
and it's right and in these cases
there's no number on the left so that's
function made zero right which is why it
ends up is ones so the addition property
is what makes Pascal's triangle Pascal's
triangle but there are other important
things too though okay for instance if
you have a look at the diagonals and you
guys have done this before right when
you're when you were just we little
people the diagonals have properties
okay so I mean an obvious one if you
take the second annual okay
what are those numbers what are those
numbers
there the county numbers or the natural
numbers or the set of positive integers
right so you have a pattern there right
but that's not the only pattern for
instance if you take the next time this
one is a little harder to recognize does
anyone recognize what 1 3 6 10 15 and so
on are those guys they're the triangular
numbers do you remember the train you
love this look I'll show you
he's on he's one right now if I make
triangle is 1 2 3 okay and here's 1 2 3
4 5 6 and I could keep going okay now
there's obvious reasons why this this
diagonal gives you the triangular
numbers right can you see it's because
the training or numbers are constructed
in the same way that that goes variable
did constructed right not a coincidence
I wonder if you recognize what the
fourth diagonal is Alea people so it
number to the diagonals
they are important sets those numbers
they're all connected
every single one okay there's other
interesting things about it I've given
you a couple can you give me some what
other kinds properties gives you I can
see at least two more probably more but
what words can you point out I mean some
are obvious training though so I said it
wait that's this one though isn't it yes
ends up if you missed me explaining what
the first property was yes sir the
addition probably actually by the way it
feeds down further than just one row to
the next right you can talk about like
two rows difference and you can see that
there are patterns there as well
obviously um I had an obvious one it's
symmetrical right it's symmetrical it
has wide symmetry each each row is
reversible that's very important you'll
see why later on okay we looked at the
numbers of how they relate to each other
right but if you have a look at the
numbers and you add them up in different
ways not just in the way that the
addition property suggests right you get
different things again okay for example
okay the first row the first row what is
the sum of all the numbers in the first
row it's one what is the sum of all the
numbers in the second row it's two what
is the sum of all the numbers in the
next row it's four and then it's eight
that's suspicious
and then it's 16 and you can probably
guess what the rest of them are right in
fact the eighth row adds up to two to
the power of n so right in I suppose you
can do cementation of something but did
you expect that that's a bit that's a
bit weird up these ones it's kind of
like with uh I mean you can see why but
this is a bit why is that there are more
properties but these are kind of the
important ones right